I've been really inspired the last
couple weeks and I've been noticing this
over Corsa probably about six months or
so I sense a real awakening by secular
people not just atheists I mean people
that are secular in that they can have
whatever belief that they want but they
want our public space our politics and
our public life to have nothing to do
with religion do you do you sense this
please tell me yes that there's been
some kind of awakening so like
constitutional this so like people who
are coming back around to 250 years ago
yes no I definitely think so I think
that it does come from more people being
willing to say that they're
non-religious it's the largest growing
minority in the country and so even
though people who self-identify as
atheists are still the most hated group
and trusted less than rate this is
totally crazy right people who are not
religious are growing in numbers and I
think they're growing in solidarity and
even religious people who are saying are
standing up for secular values and
saying we need to promote a separation
of church and state and we need to move
away from the Christian privilege that
is like under light or political
structure for way too long does it
always strike you as odd that it seems
to me the religious right on one hand
they always scream about separation of
church and state and then they're the
same ones that are always pushing
religion into the conversation
do they really scream about sever I
guess they do I don't very much you know
you could something you know real quick
saying like Kim Davis and Huckabee where
he was telling people that she shouldn't
abide by a law that she doesn't believe
in do people actually yes that's
combining church and state I was giving
them a little more credit and also I
feel like it's just a quick aside with
this whole case Davison why do people
care it's it's just like this is like
the plane crash over and over and over
right like this is really no bearing on
it if anything this one woman is
emblematic of how much this movement is
dying yeah you know the fact that
there's only one person that they can
point to and that everybody's rallying
around her and it's a joke it's becomes
such an eye roll and it to me it's
actually a good thing because it's
showing me that it's becoming more and
more marginalized and we we don't have
to take them seriously yeah you know I
completely agree I think I've sent two
tweets on the whole Kim Davis thing
which normally it would be like one of
my wheelhouse thing but it seems to me
it's like we've won this one we've won
right there's nothing that Mike Huckabee
can do reverse this no even if God
forbid he became president I say yeah he
won't write digging himself like he's
doubling down on a non-issue that's
embarrassing that it's laughable and I
think that the more that we put her in
the spotlight and the more that you know
we do the wall-to-wall CNN coverage
about her the more it gives this false
sense of legitimacy that just doesn't
exist right it's like the media is
blowing it up to be this thing where
actually the average person is like you
know what this this is a dying dinosaur
right here oh yeah she's she's a
monologue joke
that's all she is you know so one more
on this sort of broad topic so again I
had I had Sam on last week and it's been
really interesting for me to see what
happens when someone with a background
in science gets involved in politics and
I almost think that the if I have one
critique of Sam it would be that he's
placed himself in this really precarious
position out of his own bravery and as
he said it was at huge cost to him
probably personally and professionally I
would imagine do you think it's hard for
scientists or should people of a science
background get involved in the political
debate because it seems he's - in a lot
of ways he's too smart to be talking
about the way we talk about politics
because politics is so dumbed down
ie Donald Trump is leading in the
Republican polls and it's a binary right
there's no room for nuance in political
debate especially not in the eight
second sound bites that we've grown used
to and in political media
I don't know I'm of two minds about this
so I am a co-host on the skeptics guide
to the universe which is a popular
science podcast that really celebrates
skepticism evidence based thinking
debunking you know medical quackery and
things like that and the host Stephen
novella is
a renowned neuroscientist and a renowned
skeptic and he has an edit he has made
an editorial decision on this show over
the past 10 years which I just joined
like two months ago
that we don't discuss politics that
that's not relevant to the scientific
conversations now on my podcast I talk
about politics all the time sure because
I think that science is not just a topic
that you study it's not just facts and
figures in a textbook but it's a way of
thinking and it's a way of utilizing the
principles of the scientific method and
looking at evidence in order to make
informed decisions and so for me
scientific thinking is the foundation of
politics and if we could start moving
into a into kind of a direction where
this country is governed based on
evidence and not based on as Colbert
calls it truthiness right which is so
often what we do legislation is passed
because it gives you a gut check right
or because there's pork or you know all
those other reasons financial you know
incentives and things like that but so
often we make strong legislative
decisions where there's evidence
available to us and we don't base it on
the evidence and I think that if we
started moving more in that direction
we'd have a much more functional
government and definitely a more
functional economy and so I would like
to see more scientists moving into the
political arena but I can see why it
would be disconcerting if you are a
functioning University scientist because
you also oftentimes receive federal
money
sure and so then things start to get a
little bit confusing about where your
allegiance lies now Sam is not a
university scientist he was a trained
academic but it doesn't work as an
academic he's an author he does
political punditry now I mean it's part
of his job and I applaud him for that
even though you see this he's on a hit
list I'm sure he's on hit list because
of this you know it's a choice that he
made and I think it's a really brave
choice but yet I have no doubt he's on
hit list yeah it's like my Twitter feed
from today it's exactly